bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de reporter le 8 mars est
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes l'occasion pour le correspondant
de faire le bilan des luttes qu'il reste
à mener dans leurs pays respectifs
en allemagne la violence conjugale ne
cesse d'augmenter depuis six ans
l'office fédéral de police criminelle a
rendu en décembre dernier son rapport
sur le bilan des violences commises en
2020 poussé par les tensions liées au
début de la pandémie le nombre
d'agressions commises par des conjoints
ou ex conjoint a progressé de presque 5%
en un an 130 9 femmes ont ainsi été tués
en allemagne cette année là par leur
conjoint les féminicides sont devenus
plus fréquents en allemagne qu'en france
and my et vous êtes avec susana glen
leicester et willy mahler l'autrice du
reportage que nous allons diffuser dans
un instant pourquoi est ce que vous vous
êtes intéressé à ce sujet est bien une
femme meurt tous les deux jours et demi
de violences conjugales en allemagne et
lorsque la police criminelle a présenté
ce triste bilan en fin d'année dernière
il a suscité et finalement assez peu des
mois en allemagne ce qui m'a interpellé
et ce qui m'a frappé également c'est
qu'on utilisait quasiment jamais le
terme de féminicide or on sait que dans
d'autres pays comme la france par
exemple l'utilisation de ce terme
féminicide 1 qui signifie le meurtre
d'une femme par un homme parce que c'est
une femme a contribué à une prise de
conscience et on en est encore assez
loin en allemagne on vous retrouve dans
un instant mais tout de suite votre
reportage féminicide en allemagne
violence sous silence
[Musique]
la face cachée des violences ce qui se
passe derrière la porte des foyers est
une grande inconnue j'ai longtemps pensé
que j'étais la seule victime de ce genre
de violence et puis quand ça s'est su
beaucoup de femmes sont venus me dire
moi aussi je suis victime de violences
conjugales et je vis dans un petit
village alors imaginez dans les grandes
villes surtout en ce moment avec la
compagnie de coheed
il a fallu plusieurs années à sonja becq
pour se reconstruire et trouver le
courage de parler parler de ces
violences conjugales qui ont failli lui
coûter la vie à deux reprises
chez elle non loin de darmstadt dans
l'ouest de l'allemagne fennia à
conserver le journal dans lequel elle a
tenu la chronique de cette relation
toxique et violente
tout est noté depuis le premier coup
j'ai porté plainte pour tout ce qu'il a
fait
voici ce qu'elle écrit un matin d'avril
2016 et chf une phrase je n'arrive pas à
réaliser ce que tu m'as fait je suis
encore sous le choc
je n'arrive pas à croire que tu aies pu
être aussi violent tu as failli m'ôter
la vie
pardon
sphaigne à vient tout juste d'avoir un
enfant avec cet homme qui sera condamné
à un an et demi de prison avec sursis
pour coups et blessures une bagatelle au
regard des violences subies pendant des
années et pour ce qu'elle qualifie
là-dedans pectives de féminicide
la policière qui m'a reçue a fait une
erreur elle a déposé plainte contre lui
pour coups et blessures graves alors
qu'elle aurait pu déclencher une enquête
pour tentative d'homicide avec les
croisés qu'il n'y aurait pas permis de
s'en sortir avec une peine de sursis il
serait allé en prison
et c'est là que ça commence l'agresseur
se sont confirmées danser at il ce sont
forts parce qu'il se rend compte qu'il
ne lui arrive rien de grave alors rien
ne l'empêchent d'aller un peu plus loin
d'aller jusqu'aux féminicide à ce
programme
nice matin
pour venir en aide à d'autres femmes
sénia a créé il y a deux ans un groupe
d'entre aide pour victimes de violences
conjugales qui compte désormais plus de
6000 personnes il y a quelques semaines
elle a appris la mort de l'une d'entre
elles
j'ai reçu une terrible nouvelle
l'une des nôtres a été victime d'un
féminicide elle a été assassinée
une tentative d'homicide chaque jour et
trois femmes qui meurent sous les coups
de leur conjoint ou de leur ex conjoint
chaque semaine l'allemagne affiche l'un
des taux les plus élevés d'homicides
conjugaux en europe
ainsi lorsque jennifer a été retrouvée
morte dans ce champ en février 2021 à
l'orée de la petite ville de beebe times
en plein confinement les soupçons se
sont rapidement portés sur son mari voix
c'est le jugement jennyfer a été
étranglé un an auparavant son mari
l'avait déjà violemment agressé et
blessé à son domicile pendant le procès
les crises de jalousie qui rythme la vie
du couple sont au coeur des débats mais
après des aveux circonstanciés
le parquet requalifie les faits
d'assassinât qui sont passibles de la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité en
meurtre le verdict tombe en novembre
2000 21 et pour les coups et blessures
graves
le premier dédié donc cinq ans de prison
pour l'homicide 12 ans claque avec le
cumul des peines cela donne une peine de
prison de 13 ans
une sentence difficile à entendre pour
la famille et l'avocat des parties
civiles harald richter connaissait la
victime depuis sa plus tendre enfance
13 ans et demi de prison cela signifie
qu'il pourra obtenir une remise de peine
après avoir purgé les deux tiers ruby
donc il va retrouver la liberté
rapidement on sera dans une situation où
il va sortir de prison lorsque les
enfants seront encore mineure avec l
arménie et que va-t-il se passer ensuite
va-t-il demander la garde des enfants
la presse locale se fait elle aussi
l'écho du procès non loin de là à
darmstadt christine des gueules suit les
comptes rendus d'audience avec attention
elle dirige un centre de conseil destiné
aux femmes victimes de violences
conjugales sont 50 personnes ils sont
accueillis chaque année
dans les familles touchées par les
violences conjugales la situation est
particulièrement dramatique depuis le
début de la pandémie a atteint parce que
le quotidien est concentré entre les
quatre murs du foyer
alice du procès contre le mari de
jennifer qui elle aussi avait cherché de
l'aide auprès d'une association
christine dégaine critique publiquement
le verdict dans un communiqué selon elle
quand un homme tue sa partenaire c'est
souvent la culmination d'une histoire de
violence que le tribunal ne prend pas en
compte
on parle de meurtre mais quelqu'un qui a
un tel passif de violence comment
peut-on dire qu'il a agi par affecte
c'est pas possible victime qui est
plutôt que l'étranglement c'est une
manière de tuer qui durent longtemps il
faut vraiment y aller franchement ça ça
qui nous a le plus frappé andrée a cédé
alors que la justice espagnole et
française considère le meurtre sur
conjoint ou concubin comme une
circonstance aggravante
en allemagne il est souvent perçue comme
une circonstance atténuante
un avis de la cour suprême fédérale de
2008 suggère implicitement que les
victimes ont une part de responsabilité
lorsqu'elle se séparent de leurs
conjoints et que celui ci se sont
dépossédés dans ce genre de situation le
délit peut être déclenchée est déterminé
par un sentiment de détresse et de
désespoir intérieur en allemand non
juridique cela signifie que si les faits
ont été causés par la séparation et que
c'est la victime qui a souhaité cette
séparation est bien cela peut ne pas
être considérée comme un fait aggravante
une jurisprudence obsolète pour
l'association allemande des femmes
juristes qui milite pour une réforme du
code pénal
nous réclamons que le caractère 10
sexospécifique soit considéré comme une
circonstance aggravante cela permettrait
de sensibiliser la police et la justice
aux violences de genre les enquêteurs
pourraient ainsi suivre cette piste et
les juges pourraient le prendre en
compte dans l'application des peines
malgré l'entrée en vigueur en allemagne
de la convention d'istanbul contre la
violence à l'égard des femmes il y a
quatre ans le parlement allemand ne
s'est toujours pas mis d'accord sur la
définition même du mini side
les organisations de protection des
victimes dénoncent depuis des années un
manque de moyens et l'absence de
stratégie policière alors le 14 février
quand d'autres célèbrent la saint
valentin elle dénoncé violences faites
aux femmes trop souvent passée sous
silence
[Musique]
continue de penser que les violences
conjugales sont une affaire privée et
qui doit rester à la maison cela reste
un sujet tabou et les femmes victimes
continuent d'avoir honte de leur
situation
tout comme les enfants qui le subissent
honteux aussi d'en parler il faut
absolument continuer à mettre le doigt
là où ça fait mal il faut qu'on prenne
conscience de cette violence dont on ne
connaît même pas la vraie dimension et
cela commence par dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont quand une femme meurt
c'est un féminicide et ce n'est pas une
tragédie familiale car pour dénoncer et
combattre ces crimes encore faut-il
effectivement les nommer
chaque jour ces jeunes activistes
décrypte de la presse régionale et
nationale pour mettre en lumière la
couverture médiatique du féminicide
[Musique]
elle a été tuée par son voisin c'est un
cas pour nous on va en faire une capture
d'écran
une simple recherche avec quelques mots
clés
on cherche les articles qui mettent en
avant le motif de la jalousie par
exemple drame de la jalousie tragédie de
la jalousie mais aussi tous les termes
qui traite les féminicides comme des cas
isolés comme tragédie familiale ou drame
familial
en 2021 95 % des 800 articles analysés
ont recours à ce genre de faits l'isthme
pour évoquer les féminicides
l'année dernière nous n'avons trouvé que
38 articles qui utilise le terme
féminicide pour parler d'un meurtre de
femmes et on a constaté aussi qu'on
parle de plus en plus rarement de
meurtres de femmes ce terme n'a été
utilisé que trois fois ces extreme ce
recueil gamme en voie d'un drame à
nantes de manière générale on constate
une banalisation des violences faites
aux femmes on en parle toujours comme
des cas isolés mais il ya aussi une
composante raciste dans la couverture
médiatique parce que lorsque l'on parle
de crime d'honneur par exemple alors on
reconnaît le caractère structurel de ces
violences faites aux femmes mais
seulement lorsqu'ils sont commis dans
une communauté de migrants et que ce
n'est pas un problème allemand en 2019
ces activistes ont décroché une première
victoire la principale agence de presse
allemande s'est engagé à ne plus
utiliser de termes inappropriés pour
parler de ces meurtres
[Musique]
mais la prise de conscience reste
balbutiante les statistiques officielles
font état de 139 féminicide en 2020 mais
elles ne prennent en compte que les
homicides par conjoint ou ex conjoint
qui ont fait l'objet d'une enquête
pour de nombreux activistes ces chiffres
sont loin de refléter la réalité des
féminicides en allemagne sur son compte
instagram christina wolf en tient le
décompte un cimetière virtuel pour des
victimes qui reste souvent anonymes
ceux dont la population ne se rend pas
compte c'est que les statistiques de
nous disposons sur les délits des
sphères intrafamiliales aimé ty ne
prennent pas en compte les féminicides
commis par des pairs sur leur fille a
des frères sur leurs soeurs par des fils
sur leur mère par des cousins ou des
hommes comme des harceleurs par exemple
tout cela mis sous le tapis et donc
l'opinion publique ne prend pas
conscience de dimension du problème
alors comment briser le silence qui
entoure ces violences faites aux femmes
en allemagne à berlin plusieurs
associations féministes se sont unis
pour créer un réseau contre tous les
féminicides
si vous êtes d'accord pour la
manifestation du 8 mars on s'est dit que
ce serait cool de former un blog dédié à
la lutte contre les féminicides avec des
affiches clairement identifiés
après 202 pandémie et une augmentation
des violences faites aux femmes elles
veulent multiplier les actions pour
rappeler le gouvernement a sa
responsabilité et à l'application de la
convention d'istanbul
pour l'instant il ne s'est vraiment pas
passé grand chose on nous promet la mise
en place d'un centre de coordination
nationale chargée d'évaluer toutes les
violences de genre et de proposer des
solutions pour les places d'hébergement
par exemple rate mais pour l'instant ce
centre de coordination n'existe toujours
pas remplacés par des croix de niro est
avec
nous
il ne suffira pas de changer les lois
pour régler le problème il faut vraiment
une énorme prise de conscience
il faut parler et reconnaître les
problèmes rencontrés par les femmes
lorsqu'elles cherchent un logement
lorsqu'elles sont dans une situation de
dépendance financière a plu parce que
cette précarité peut aussi conduire au
féminicide c'est ce qu'il nous faut en
fait un vrai sursaut de la société
croate zones riches
pour l'heure l'allemagne ne compte que
sept mille places en foyer d'accueil
pour victimes de violences conjugales il
en faudrait 14000 de plus alors en
attendant une stratégie nationale contre
les violences faites aux femmes les
féminicides continue une vingtaine de
femmes ont déjà été tués depuis le début
de l'année 2022 en allemagne
[Musique]
voilà pour ces témoignages très durs à
noyer est toujours avec nous anne
quelles sont les principales difficultés
rencontrées par les victimes de
violences conjugales en allemagne
via les organisations dead aux victimes
aux victimes critiques depuis très
longtemps déjà un manque de moyens
généraliser un manque de moyens qui
touche aussi la police par exemple
puisque les autorités peuvent délivrer
des mesures d'éloignement contre des
maris ou des conjoints violents mais
celles ci sont très difficilement
contrôlable les organisations
souhaiterait que la police puisse avoir
au cours comme en espagne à des
bracelets électroniques
dans certaines régions les policiers
sont sensibilisés aux violences
conjugales dans d'autres il n'existe
absolument aucun programme pour
sensibiliser et former les officiers de
police à l'aide à ces femmes et aux
interventions il y a également un
problème au niveau de l'arsenal
juridique comme vous avez pu le voir
dans notre reportage il y a un gros
déficit dans la prévention et puis comme
le souligne également la directrice du
centre d'accueil pour femmes victimes de
violence conjugale que nous avons
rencontrés il ya aussi un énorme
problème d'information du grand public
elle n'hésite pas d'ailleurs à attirer
le parallèle avec la prévention du
terrorisme pour marquer les esprits
ecoutez-la terrorisme aux sarcasmes aux
noces en allemagne le terrorisme a fait
moins de dégâts que ces meurtres
incessant de femmes
mais la différence c'est qu'on parle de
terrorisme de manière très objective
dans la presse et dans l'espace public
on agit contre en investissant beaucoup
d'argent quel coup on se demande
vraiment pourquoi ce n'est pas possible
de lutter de la même manière contre les
féminicides
c'est incompréhensible
et que compte faire le gouvernement
bien le nouveau gouvernement s'est
engagé dans son contrat de coalition qui
est en fait un son programme
gouvernemental à lutter bien plus
massivement contre les violences faites
aux femmes cela passe par l'application
de la convention d'istanbul bien sûr par
la mise sur pied d'une stratégie
nationale contre les violences faites
aux femmes par le financement également
de nouvelles places dans les foyers
d'accueil pour femmes victimes de
violence conjugale par plus de
prévention c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement allemand semble vraiment
déterminé à s'engager dans la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
en allemagne et c'est donc accueilli
très positivement par les organisations
d'aidé aux victimes par les associations
qui salue bien évidemment tout ce qui
figure dans le contrat de coalition mais
elles attendent tout maintenant bien sûr
aussi que le gouvernement passe de la
parole aux actes merci beaucoup and my
et merci à vous de votre attention pour
rester avec nous l'information continue
sur france 24
[Musique]